بالفعل يعني ما زالت الاعمال العسكريه
الكبيره والعنيفه مستمره لا يتوقف القصف
المتبادل ما زلنا نسمع منذ الصباح الباكر
ومنذ عده ايام اصوات اطلاق النار الكثيف
وايضا ذوي الانفجارات هنا في المدينه في
قلب المدينه وعلى احياء اطراف المدينه كما
ان مدن اخرى
لا اعلم هل تسمع اصوات الانفجارات
والاطلاق الصواريخ هنا بكثافه يعني يعني
ارتفعت وتيره القصف المتبادل بالفعل راويه
لدرجه كبيره في الايام الاخيره هناك ايضا
حضور وتواجد كبير للجنود المستجدين الروس
الذين يصلون الى مدينه دانياس ثم ينتقلون
الى الجبهات الى الجبهات المختلفه طبعا
الجبهات كلها مشتعله جبهه جنوبيه والجبهه
الشماليه وحتى اطراف مقاطعه
هناك منطقه ليمان وكوبيان استشهد تقدم
للقوات الروسيه وسيطر على بلدات اضافيه
لكن المحور الاكثر سخونه دائما هو باخمت
المنطقه الشماليه من مقاطعه
ماذا عن اجلاء السكان من حول هذه المدينه
ناحيه روسيا ومن داخل ضخمه ناحيه اوكرانيا
بالفعل راوية تشهد المنطقه في شمال مقاطعه
ديناسك وهي مدينه باخموت وما حولها اجلاء
لجميع السكان الذين يقطنون في البلدات
والقرى المجاوره للمدينه ذلك مع الدفع
اعداد كبيره من الجنود الروس كامدادات
عسكريه بشريه وبالاليات ايضا لتلك المنطقه
لتعزيز القوات التي تقاتل حول مدينه
باخموت ايضا من الناحيه الاخرى جانب
الاوكراني اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه عن
اجلاء جميع السكان من المدينه لابد ان
هناك يعني تحضير لعمليه عسكريه كبيره اكبر
من التي نشهدها هذه الايام حول مدينه
باقمت بالفعل تقدمت قوات فاجنر من الناحيه
الجنوبيه من مدينه باخموت في عمق المدينه
انطلاقا من مدينه ايفانجرات كما ان قوات
فاغنر ايضا ما زالت تقاتل نعم مدينه
بريخوفكا في المنطقه الشماليه هي البوابه
الشماليه لمدينه باقمه وقتال شوارع عن
المقاطعه نسمي المعارك هناك بانها الاكثر
شراسه